come on girls the ice creams gonna melt
oh wow this sauce is amazing you said it
was promoting a movie carrying a three
attitude I got it I got it
nice to meet you Morty listen if you
ever need anybody murdered please give
me a call at your very own car no code
of ethics I will kill anyone anywhere
children animals old people doesn't
matter
I just love killing oh holy [ __ ]
thanks kids you figured it out well
summer did kind of weird that you were
that willing to sell my existence out
for some trim Morty Melissa I forgive
you both because you know what I learned
today something important the teenage
mind is its own worst enemy oh I also
learned this operation Phoenix is not
the fallback I thought it would be I
guess it's a grip on baby
grandpa I'm just gonna go take a dump is
it cool if I use the level 9 bathroom
we'll give me that d 99 this is the
commander-in-chief of the good good
enough
he's a spy pull them up I'm gonna go
take a [ __ ] take a kid
memo but we know we can go back to that
time
[Music]
your get out of the booth take all your
clothes off and fold yourself twelve
times you got it is it ready yes we can
bring it online now do it
I am Phoenix person Phoenix person is
that what we settled on I thought we all
agreed on cyber bird you said you didn't
care what he was called as long as we
brought him back
yeah but Phoenix person find it who
cares
first thing that's different no more dad
more tea
he threatened to turn me in to the
government so I made him in the
government go away oh I play simple as a
de facto patriarch of your family and
your universe your mom wouldn't have
accepted me if I came home without you
and your sister so now you know the real
reason I rescued I just took over the
family Morty if you tell your mom or
sister I let any of this on tonight and
they'll take my side because I'm a hero
Morty now you're gonna code you whatever
I say Morty rules forever and I'll go on
they'll find some more that Mulan
nestled on teriyaki dipping sauce Morty
that's what this is all about Lori
that's my one-armed man I'm not driven
by avenging my dead family Morty that
was fake Oh driven by fighting that big
nugget saw nothing I want that Mulan
McNugget sauce morning that's my series
Arthur hello it takes nine seasons
I want my McNugget dipping sauce last
one is not Morty that's what's going to
take authority season nine more seasons
morning nine more seasons until I get
that dipping sex water 97 more years
morning Oh without exec stock
hey everybody is Charlie Adult Swim
trying to get you hyped up for Rick and
Morty with more WTF moments but they're
also screening a bunch of material early
so I have details for how you might be
able to watch episodes if you're new to
the channel I will be doing Rick and
Morty videos throughout season 3 be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I also think I have a pretty good idea
of when the season is going to premiere
based on this tour that Adult Swim is
doing is airing a bunch of early
material so if you live in one of the
places or you live near one of the
places they're going to be screening
stuff you might have a chance to see
episodes early because they say they're
going to be presenting never-before-seen
stuff from upcoming seasons it's called
Adult Swim presents on the green so what
they're doing is a bunch of live
showings they're starting in Phoenix and
making their way across the summer all
the way to Santa Barbara California it's
sort of a festival in conjunction with a
bunch of screenings so they have all the
festival stuff where you play games like
they roll out a whole bunch of content
then later in the evening they're
following that with the
free promotional screening the language
disk reads we'll take a look at what's
on the horizon for the network with
unaired episodes never-before-seen
pilots specials and loads of other
Williams Street favorites so Williams
Street is just the in-house Adult Swim
production team but it sounds like this
is your best shot at seeing new Rick and
Morty before anybody else now here's the
date so this might give you a pretty
good idea of when season 3 is going to
be dropping the first two or days June
13th in Phoenix Arizona then pretty much
every couple days they move to a new
city the last date is June 30th in Santa
Barbara California so because that's a
Friday it sounds like episode 2 is gonna
drop sometime in the next couple days
after that like Saturday or Sunday which
is basically fourth of July weekend in
the United States pretty much just a
weekend when everybody gets a day off of
work just get super drunk during the day
so if you live internationally then
you'll still be watching it the same way
you always watch it they tend to do
marathon special screenings during the
summer during big holidays so all signs
are just pointing to this but you guys
can let me know do you actually think
that it's going to be fourth of July
weekend when episode two drops they
could drop it before then but I think
most of us felt like it was going to be
late June early July anyway so you've
also probably noticed that the Rick and
Morty social accounts have been posting
way more often they tend to do that as
they ramped up for big release so here
the actual tour dates it's June 13th in
Phoenix Arizona
June 17th in Spokane Washington June
19th in Portland the 23rd in Park City
26th in Boise Idaho and in the last day
June 30th in Santa Barbara so I totally
thought about booking a flight to
Phoenix Arizona just so I could catch
all that stuff first
but if anything drops online I'll
totally do a video for it leave all your
requests for bonus videos there's going
to be a whole bunch of Rick and Morty's
this summer along with Game of Thrones
speaking of which Justin roiland was
spotted with the Game of Thrones
creators and Peter Dinklage it looked
like he just got to see the first
episode of season 7 because he's a huge
Game of Thrones fan in their huge Rick
and Morty fans and they even did the
intergalactic cable parody tiny people
so while you wait for everything you can
click here for all my season 3 videos
and you can click here for my episode 1
video thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]